les enfants du président assassiné qui
vivent à paris son parti pour beyrouth
ce soir dans la communauté libanaise
pourtant accoutumée depuis 15 ans un
temps étant de catastrophe
c'est la consternation isabelle steiss
dès l'annoncé de la nouvelle ils se sont
succédé dans la résidence parisienne de
rené mouawad des proches venus apporter
leur soutien aux deux enfants du
président assassiné peu après sans un
mot rima et michel moawad quitter leur
domicile pour rejoindre leur mère à
beyrouth l'ambassadeur du liban à paris
étaient à leurs côtés
c'est une page du
qu'en faire ap c'est votre souffrance il
y encore trois semaines toute la famille
vivait ici dans cet appartement
michel moawad évoquait alors l'élection
son père avec espoir et clairvoyance
c'est l'extrémisme en fait qui a qui a
qui en train de gouverner depuis pas mal
de temps au débat et c'est pour ça que
je trouve que l'élection de mon père
pourrait être une chance pour le liban
parce que il a toujours été connu comme
un modéré et là il a toujours passé dans
les moments les plus difficiles dans les
régions ouest
même dans les derniers événements et en
82 pendant toutes les années il n'a
jamais arrêté le contact avec les autres
régions
et tout ça parce que il a toujours pensé
que quand on gouverne qu'un pays comme
le liban divisée ne serait pas viable
aujourd'hui les appels n'ont pas cessé à
radio-orient des libanais qui voulaient
exprimer leurs émotions pour les
militants chrétiens des forces
libanaises
il faut voir une main étrangère derrière
cet assassinat
vous savez que les libanais sont la
victime et non pas les acteurs et son la
victime du terrorisme d'état et non pas
les acteurs et dans le cas présent mon
awad a été assassiné au coeur de
beyrouth ouest au sein du dispositif
syrien d'occupation ce soir les libanais
de paris sont à l'écouté de leur radio
ils craignent que la violence ne
s'abatte à nouveau sur ceux qui sont
restés au pays